foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream q a number 151 we
got a lot of questions to answer as a
result of Prior q and A's that could not
or did not happen that's right so we
think we should get to it all right
let's get to it we got three from
Discord
uh we're gonna start with the one from
two weeks ago going reverse
chronological order before hitting the
questions that you guys can ask live at
darkhorsesubmissions.com first question
from the Discord this week which you can
access at either of our patreons many
people are considering homeschooling
their children to protect them from the
excesses of woke ideology but this comes
with its own challenges of course could
you talk about the possible dangers or
drawbacks of homeschooling
so I will say that we
um
we used to have a lot of students at
Evergreen who had been homeschooled and
they were among the most
uh innovative
creative and rigorous thinkers that we
had not to say that there that we didn't
have plenty of extraordinary thinkers
among the skooled but we also had
unschooled students but you know we
didn't Evergreen did not attract the
traditional sort of like the Christian
traditional homeschooler types of of
which there is a sort and I can't speak
to what effect that might have on the
developing mind and personality of those
so schooled but the the homeschooled
students that we got were really
remarkable
and uh therefore the big consideration
that I had and heard both from other
parents of young children when we had
very young children and from talking to
those students about what
um what they had Learned was uh
considerations for the parents time
whether or not they can they have the
personality they have the skill set they
don't have the work the paid work that
they have to be doing Etc and then the
socialization for for the children like
you know some sort of a homeschooling as
a lot of people discovered and created
during covid a like actually we're going
to make a pod undo you know five
families for instance uh which is still
not the same kind of possibility for
socialization as you were getting a big
school on the other hand it much more
closely approximates what you might have
gotten in earlier human history yeah I
would agree with that I would add that
one danger is that it appears that math
is often not well taught at home which I
take to be the result of often parents
don't quite have it down and so they're
not in a good position to teach which is
not to say that Math teachers
are you know Math teachers
are going to be competent at a level and
it's going to be rare that they're
capable of dealing with somebody who has
unusually high capacity but yeah but
anyway it is one thing that one should
think carefully about because those
students as good as they were were often
um deficient in math yep yep no I think
that's right
um I think
I think it's more likely that parents
who are inclined to homeschool will have
talents that don't tend towards the
mathematical that if there are uh if
there's one parent in a parenting unit
who has those Tendencies they are
probably more likely to be the one who's
earning the money that allows the other
one to not be working outside the home
for instance uh and
you know whereas I had a parent who was
excellent at teaching me math and taught
me much more than I was learning from
any of the teachers who I had who didn't
know very much about math I think that's
very rare
uh but I will just repeat your concern
which is that it's the very rare math
teacher who knows what they're doing so
it's the it's perhaps the rarer
homeschooling parent who does know what
they're doing mathematically speaking
but it's also unfortunately the rare
math teacher I would say
likely to be the case math is difficult
to teach well and because of that
it's you know it's harder for a math
teacher to do it well so what a math
teacher will do
uh maybe above what somebody trying to
Cobble together a curriculum of their
own would do and cobbled together a
curriculum probably means
getting a curriculum from somewhere
which means not really understanding or
probably even remembering how some of
these things are done
so anyway there's a special Hazard and
there might be some uh remedy I mean
there is a lot of cool stuff
available
online I've pointed to VI heart before
I'm very fond of the way she describes
mathematical principles
um in intuitive ways uh
you know obviously Khan Academy and
other things provide resources but I
think thinking very deliberately about
math is probably a good idea yeah
um
yeah a lot more to be said I can't
remember actually if
our book Hanukkah there's got to the
21st century originally had two chapters
on education uh and in
crunching it down to one and losing a
whole bunch of other stuff I think maybe
the the bit that we did on homeschooling
um got erased so I'm not sure how much
we have actually put out into the
Universe on this on this topic but
um
but certainly given uh given what is
true of so many of the schools now uh it
is a choice that a lot of very smart
people are making yep
second question from the Discord this
week
Canada is set to allow medical
assistance in dying maid for individuals
suffering from mental illness
plus doctors in Canada are being told
that they should suggest maity to
eligible patients before the patient
brings it up
thoughts
um it's two very different questions
right or it's two very different
policies
I believe
This falls under the heading of what
could possibly go right
with regard to the second
nope okay I would say there is
I am not arguing that there is no
abstract case to be made
for instances the problem is once you
create the category it's a little like
the death penalty
right
there are cases in which the death
penalty makes sense
the problem is in order for the death
penalty to be applied in those cases you
have to have the death penalty and then
the death penalty gets used in all kinds
of cases where it doesn't make sense and
in fact you end up putting innocent
people to death right so problem is if
you create and being opposed to the
death penalty doesn't mean that you
think that there is no crime uh that
doesn't necessarily warrant
right punishment there there are crimes
for which it's the right punishment the
problem is there's no mechanism that's
sufficiently careful that can be trusted
with deciding when you've got such a
case right and the same thing can be
said here certainly there are people
with a very valid argument just as there
are people with a very valid argument
against
um
uh abortion right that is to say
logically consistent argument about the
reason that it should never be available
I don't think they are right but there
will be people who make the same kind of
argument here which is that this is not
for humans to decide
um and I think the fact that those
people will typically be
very much a minority tells us the answer
that actually we have to decide but in
this case there's no mechanism to do it
um this will be abused that means people
will be put to death
who were coerced and so again no there's
two different things so medical
assistance and dying
four people suffering from mental
illness that's what I thought you were
talking about there but now you segued
without saying that you were segueing
into talking about
um doctors in Canada being told they
should suggest it well I don't see these
things as very distinct because the
question is
what happens in the case
that they don't suggest it
right in other words how is that policed
exactly right can a doctor hint
but not suggest in the case that
suggestion is not on the table so in
other words my point is they're opening
up a mechanism and a use case which is
mentally ill people and the question is
well what happens then what what becomes
fashionable what loopho I mean you know
we already have a an effective loophole
which I believe must exist but because
it's a loophole and not a policy
the thing that is done when people have
reached the very end of their lives
and in effect they are not allowed to be
euthanized but they can be treated for
pain and painkillers can euthanize so as
long as your intent is uh to
uh to reduce their pain you can
effectively kill them that thing
obviously has a
set of scenarios for which you want to
have it available right why put somebody
through the torment of the very final
stage of some terribly painful disease
when the end is unavoidable right but
what happens once you have that
mechanism available right is it opens an
opportunity for abuse of the worst kind
so
I think the line short of it is
um even those of us who believe
that there's probably an argument to be
made in some cases should be well aware
that the abuse of this principle in this
case is a huge Hazard and almost there's
almost no way this could be deployed
that we won't see abuse
yeah
um
I think that's true
uh I guess I think that's true for
medical assistance and dying for
physical illness as well but I fall
in a different place on on that
and
whereas it might seem like Well Physical
versus mental illness it leaves a
physical Trace you can find the thing
that presumes that Western medicine is
right about a whole lot of things and it
also presumes that pain leaves a mark
right so different people experience
pain very differently and it really is
assessment there is no objective measure
of the amount of pain you're
experiencing your doctors can look at
the amount to which a person is riddled
with cancer in particular sort and say
they're in a lot of pain of that much we
can be sure but you know some people
with some you know particular pain
sensitivities and experiences in life
and other things may experience exactly
the same diagnosis and you know Imaging
that is true is a true physical
representation of their body differently
so I feel like already we're on that
slippery slope with uh what is the
acronym maid medical assistant dying for
physical ailments and
um
I think you're right I think I agree
that it becomes too slippery
for mental illness and certainly that
doctors proposing it is is obscene
uh but it's not a clean break it's we're
already we're already well into slippery
territory if you know if I am already
willing to touch my mic I am well I am
already well in a slippery territory uh
if I say actually I I am in favor of
you know death With Dignity for those
who choose it if they are an extreme
physical pain
uh uh well okay I think I think my
position is not well represented then
um I would argue that there is a
fundamental human right not to exist
right and that nobody can tell you that
you have to exist now this runs into
trouble does that mean that anybody who
commits a heinous crime and goes to
prison has the right to opt out
presumably not
um so that right then to not exist can't
be absolute
um but I believe it's pretty close to it
on the other hand I believe that lots of
people temporarily feel that that's what
they want right and that we have an
obligation not to
um
uh to allow those temporary feelings to
you know
physical illness
we have a greater understanding that we
currently think is accurate and I am I
have a high certainty that it's accurate
that a physical illness we can tell
that's that is terminal as opposed to a
mental illness which in I mean in fact
many mental illnesses Abate with age
right right so
the my concern here is the
medicalization of that right the right
exists I believe there's ambiguity the
problem is we are living in an era in
which
the Hippocratic Oath
is back on its heels
yeah right lots of doctors have been
violating the Hippocratic oath and their
obligation to informed consent and so
the point is the most basic principles
that make medicine thinkable
are in Jeopardy at that moment you want
to enter you want to medicalize the
question of whether to be or not to be
that doesn't seem like a reasonable
thing to do it seems like a gateway to a
a an unthinkable realm now there has
always been a concern that the people
uh the people who
cannot
manage to exercise their right not to
exist and therefore need help are really
the gray area
um and I don't I don't know that
anybody's figured out how you create an
opportunity for somebody who's truly
facing
an unthinkable future
um
because you can't accomplish it
themselves right how you do though if
it's not MediCal what is it exactly
um so I don't know the answer to that
question I will say that there is a case
uh
an evergreen student who neither of us
knew who committed suicide uh while we
were professors and she documented her
thought process extensively online which
made for excruciating reading
um but I it is a case that has always
you know stuck out to me because
the hell that she was living in
was so unthinkably terrible that I
totally understood why this was her
conclusion and it wasn't that she rushed
to it right she had been raped and was
basically incapable of controlling he'd
been raped as a child she had been
incapable of controlling the ongoing
Terror that this induced
um
and you know she described
I like dreams in which she was
chewing nails and glass and that these
this was just an every night phenomenon
and so anyway I I it did sort of
wake me up to what
a purely mental anguish could look like
that would
make the case that said I you know
this person sought help it didn't work
there's a lot of bad help out there yeah
but I felt at the time you know I was
reading about it I learned about her
after she died and I felt that it was a
terrible terrible tragedy that nobody
figured out how to get her to the help
that I assume must exist but I was also
left with the answer
how do you know it exists how do you
know that this person's trauma is
reversible that's a kind of faith on
your part
um so anyway that's that's where I was
left with it
um but I think the problem is you're
you're combining two Realms here one is
a philosophical Realm
right do you have the right not to be if
you find life terrible I feel that you
do yeah do we have to provide a
mechanism so everybody can exercise that
right
maybe we do but if we provide that
mechanism what will it be used for it
will be used to off people who wouldn't
exercise that right so we can't have the
mechanism and I don't know the
resolution for those puzzle pieces but I
know they're all on the table yeah no
yeah
it's it's beyond slippery yeah yeah
okay third question from the Discord
this week
subliminal art God excuse me subliminal
art like that used in the Balenciaga am
I pronouncing that right okay let's
start over Balenciaga
subliminal art like that used in the
Balenciaga teddy bear bonded shoot
um is far more powerful than most of us
understand is it possible that it has
been weaponized in this particular way
for much longer than we realize
is it perhaps a Major Tool in the mouse
formation surrounding many of the
cultural and political issues of our day
if we were ever to get out of this mess
if you will be deep programming for a
long time to come
yeah
um so for those happily uninitiated into
this particular story
um we're not going to show pictures but
um
the
High fashion brand I guess Balenciaga
which as I told you after this happened
by the extent of my knowledge of them
came from a Simpsons special that they
did uh that The Simpsons and Balenciaga
came together for some amount of time
and
did something
um
there is a photo shoot that involved
little girls holding teddy bears in
bondage regalia and one of the pictures
had um
had court documents for my child porn
case visible in the background a case in
which a court struck down a restriction
I believe enabling so I don't know that
but that would fit
um anyway and you know they did it and
then they I guess deleted
all of it but of course there's lots of
screenshots yeah but I want to uh but
the question is about soleno art yeah I
wanna we have to as long as we're going
to talk about this case I think we have
to
um do it justice we don't know anything
about what accounts for this thing
showing up as part of their
PR yeah maybe this Corporation has
pedophilic sympathies and somehow was
winking at some clientele
I actually find it hard to imagine that
that would be
something that they would do even if the
brand right yeah doesn't make any sense
so there are possibilities for example
that something that wanted to
or that was hired to do the art
broadcast this stuff and that it wasn't
the corporation itself
that also seems weird
right the chances that such a thing
brings the police to your door
presumably would make that a very risky
uh thing to engage in so why what's the
point of broadcasting this well but the
police don't come to your door for this
that's that's part of the point that it
seems really obvious to a lot of us and
there are a whole lot of people on the
on the left who are like what is your
problem right I get I get it and I'm
horrified by the fact that that's the
era we're living in right and I do think
that this has something let's put it
this way we never got an accounting of
what happened with Epstein right so the
point is we know that somehow
pedophilia and
political
power
there's some story we don't know we
don't know what role it's playing so
anyway I'm thoroughly disturbed by that
what I want to avoid is assuming that
dots that seem to so easily connect
right once you know what are you
imagining is connected or what are you
saying people are regarding as connected
once you know to look into this
particular fashion House's photo shoot
the evidence is staring you in the face
but how many million people looked at
these images and didn't think is there
some message here they just thought
fashion is weird right but that I mean
that's that's part of the point of the
question right that this is right but
this gets you on a subliminal level for
for many people maybe or maybe it's uh
economic maybe it's sabotage maybe it's
the time traveling money printer
in other words what if somebody decided
to sabotage a competing brand
right by tarring it with the stigma of
pedophilia what if
somebody decided to take some millions
of dollars and turn it into billions of
dollars by shorting
a stock that could then be made to tank
now I will say I tested that hypothesis
by looking at what I think is the stock
price and it did not plunge nearly as
much as I would have imagined so maybe
time traveling money printers off the
table as an explanation here but I guess
my point would be what where it failed I
mean it doesn't it doesn't sound likely
to me to me but just because it didn't
work doesn't mean it was well it doesn't
sound likely I don't know why I would
imagine
that time traveling money printer being
a logically reasonable mechanism to
hypothesize that we will see events in
which it's it's the opposite of pump and
dump right right is that what you're
talking about sabotage yeah I'm talking
it's just a lot of ways I don't know I
I was I was simultaneously suggesting to
you that actually the fact that it
didn't work doesn't necessarily mean it
didn't happen and saying it doesn't seem
that likely to me I don't know what
doesn't seem that likely doesn't seem
likely to explain this pattern where it
doesn't seem likely that people will
make money through this mechanism
seem likely to be what explains this
particular instantiation because uh the
idea that there are
photographers I don't know what the
names for all of the people involved in
in manifesting such a shoot are yeah
photographers being one of many types of
people who would have been required
their producers Runners whatever
um that there were but there are a
couple of people and it you know would
have taken more than one but it didn't
take the entire brand it would have
taken a couple of people
um to say oh we're gonna we're gonna do
this
um
who and that there are some people in
the entertainment industry who have
these you know interests and intentions
doesn't surprise me at all that just
seems more likely to be what happened I
don't really understand it I don't
understand that position because first
of all I may be wrong it may be that the
stigma of pedophilia is not enough
really it's just more parsimonious
because you still require those people
that I'm talking about for what you're
talking about but then you also require
an additional layer
not I don't think that I don't think
parsimony argues against this because to
the extent that this mechanism
that creating a historical event that
alters the price of something that
allows you to take money and multiply it
that
all you would have to do
is cut somebody in for enough money that
it would be worth them wrecking their
own career if they could be guaranteed
that they weren't going to jail if it
was
so I I'm not arguing that this happened
I am not arguing that Balenciaga is not
fully guilty of broadcasting a message
that something inside that Corporation
isn't witting all I'm arguing is we have
no idea what this was and there are a
lot of possibilities and because there
are a lot of possibilities and we have
no idea what it was I think
um it is you know it is incumbent on us
not to LEAP to conclusions that what
happened is a major fashion house
broadcast its internal uh
what would it be a tolerance of or uh
well geez I never I never heard that
conclusion at all I never thought that
conclusion I certainly never ran into it
and I didn't spend a lot of time with
the story because it just it's so
disturbing yeah um but I had to think
about it about it a little bit
um and I know it never occurred to me
that people were saying like Ah that's
there for what this fashion house is
about
but that seems like a crazy leap
well I I guess I don't know what
conversation we're having then I thought
that people assumed that Balenciaga knew
what it was doing
rather than some
lower down folks inside Balenciaga use
this photo shoot to broadcast some
message that they liked and uh that you
know
the brand had nothing to do with it
that's certainly well that's the
possibility I think I think you're a
strong man in my position I didn't say
had nothing to do with it you know
there's got to be presumably there's
some Chain of Command right like for any
for any photo shoot that ends up
representing the brand there's got to be
some you know someone at each position
who's like signed off signed off signed
off yep um and very often those sign
offs are are ripped you know it didn't
look right or oh it's fine oh it wasn't
she cute like you know there's
everything from like I got it and yes
thank you for this which
there may be a few of those people but I
don't assume that that's most of what
those sign ups would have been if that's
what was happening okay but then I don't
really even understand what the issue is
because we know there's way too much of
this in public right we know for example
that musk has been purging people who uh
were engaged in this stuff on Twitter I
don't know who you think we is most
people don't know this
what I'm saying is I don't understand it
seems to me that what makes this story
unique is that there is a major brand
involved but if the major brand is only
tangentially involved because something
inside of it was you know wrote signing
off on stuff that other people decided
to abuse for their own Twisted purposes
then
um
you know it's like every other story
it's the major brand that makes it
interesting and my point is I don't
actually know what role the major brand
was playing here if any I I don't either
I mean I've just I've never seen
anything like this so I don't I I think
we're just talking across purposes now
I'm not I'm not sure what
what you think has been revealed by me
saying I don't I well I I hope I'm not
getting your position wrong I will just
say my position is there's something
about the story that feels like oh my
God look at these dots that connect and
my point is do they connect because this
was a very thinly veiled something that
we can now see or do they connect
because somebody wants us to connect
them for purposes that are not
transparent right and I'm saying I I
don't understand the story with dots
connecting like that that's not how I
read it that's why I didn't I didn't do
that analysis on it all right
um
but
uh
regardless it was not I don't know how
many people it was seen by and the
people I know who saw it saw it for the
grotesquery that it was
I don't know to what degree people did
see it and thought Oh once yeah after
the story was revealed rather than how
many people saw the campaign yes so I'm
trying to get back to the question okay
subliminal art to what degree people who
saw it who don't think oh God what are
you doing what is going on here who
don't see it for what it is
may have been affected by it that's you
know once you've once you know what it
is the subliminal part doesn't work on
you right it's it's not like that so the
question here is put aside this
particular example right
to what degree
are you know the examples the examples
that I learned about when I was doing
like film and cultural critique in high
school because that's what you did in LA
in the 80s at some schools
um was you know were examples that that
are obvious in retrospect right where
they were actually like you know words
that were inserted in like one in every
they're at 1 20th of a second in frames
occasionally during like TV shows or you
know some like back when it was actually
frames per second yeah right uh that
actually got people don't want to drink
Coke or whatever it was like actual
subliminal advertising that was too fast
it went by too fast for your conscious
brain to know what had happened but yeah
you did kind of have a hankering for
Coke afterwards yep so that was the
crude stuff of the film era and uh there
has been much described of you know what
is possible since
and the question at one level which is
yeah it's it's a huge question is to
what degrees is happening and
specifically to what degree is the mass
formation potentially you know around
things like coveted vaccines and there
is no effective treatment except for
Pax load or whatever uh due to
things like that
and I don't re I don't really know how
to answer the question because it feels
I don't even have like there's lots of
examples that you can bring up over in
trans space over in trans ideology space
of of normalizing grotesqueries yeah
right but how what is other than like
smiling celebrities like you know other
than Dolly Parton singing about vaccines
to the tune of Jolene in advance of
getting a vaccine
right like that that was effective and
but it wasn't subliminal well no I think
the problem is subliminal uh is probably
a Continuum yeah how subliminal just
barely or thoroughly yeah and how
complex a channel is it I would say you
know look all advertising are almost all
sophisticated advertising
is subliminal right the fact that
a car company
who knows that if it hires an attractive
woman to sit either in the driver's seat
or in the passenger seat and to give a
particular look to the camera that that
will cause either male uh potential
buyers to feel enticed or female
potential buyers to feel desired or
whatever that causes them to view a car
a mechanical device in some way right so
human sexuality then affects the way
people view a car enough the the
billions of dollars that are spent on
this kind of advertising is worth doing
that tells us that brands
that say advertising doesn't work are
being out competed by brands that say it
does work and give me some and so
basically I would say the channel exists
the fact that you don't know that you
have a positive sense about this car
because of the attractive model that
somebody paid to sit in it right tells
you it's subliminal right you were not
conscious of your change and belief
about this car
um
and the question then is given that the
subliminal Channel exists enough for
advertising to be based on it
what other stuff is being sent down this
pipe and
um I think we saw
I mean we saw very sophisticated
propaganda
with respect to covid that caused lots
of people to misunderstand what the
question was who their friends were all
of that stuff yeah so my basic answer to
the question itself is Balenciaga aside
I think propaganda has been turned high
tech it is highly effective and that you
have to use some mechanism like what we
discussed in the main podcast in which
you're comparing your model over time
and saying you know to the extent that
propaganda causes you to believe wrong
things your model won't be very
predictive so you could detect it and
you could say huh I wonder what I'm
paying attention to that isn't helping
me because my model's not getting better
in fact it's getting worse right whereas
if you're good at tuning that stuff out
then your model should get
better rapidly because you're not being
steered
so anyway I think it's a big problem
uh and I think we've recently seen just
how catastrophic its results can be as
the short answer
okay first question from
darkhorsesubmissions.com
I actually came in many weeks ago
how do you feel about the Pinker Blank
Slate conclusion that based upon twin
study data parents are fungible
did we not do this we did not do it we
did not do it I think we were planning
to go and then the live stream didn't
work there didn't work okay
um
we we can't fully explore this here nor
am I uh ready to do it but the idea that
parents are fungible is nonsense yeah um
and we can tell that it's nonsense based
on the degree to which
parents invest in
um
lessons in other words our
instincts is the wrong word but for
these purposes it works well enough our
instincts to invest in the education of
our children is the result of the fact
that that has had important impacts and
the problem is those studies
are not what they purport to be they're
a limited right they use certain
measures and proxies
there's no telling what they miss but B
there's the entire Madness surrounding
what happened to the idea of
heritability
right and
um
the
the problem is that heritability became
narrowly defined in uh the post-dna era
after the discovery of DNA as the
genetic material
our understanding of heritability got
narrowed and it got defined around
certain oxymorons right like defining
heritability as the degree of phenotypic
variation due to uh the differences in
alleles and the problem is things that
are affixed that is to say things that
everybody has you know the fact of a
human knows right every human has a nose
the human nose is not heritable
why because everybody's got one right no
shape is heritable because we get
different alleles that affect the shape
but the point is that is
counterintuitive for a reason because
this term doesn't mean what we think it
means so anyway every time I've delved
into this
what I've found is conclusions about
heritability that are overly
instantiated because nobody really
understands that the bodies are buried
under that false concept
um anyway so I guess I would leave it
there but uh
okay yes parents matter irrespective of
what the experiments claim to tell you
there may be surprising ways in which
they don't but do they not matter at all
no that's nonsense
okay so reminder that some of these
questions are coming from previous live
streams
um
this is from two weeks ago
is there any room in the calculation of
whether to forgive for the impact of
Terror on the ability of people to
behave logically
with the amygdala in the driver's seat
good judgment often goes out the window
there was a lot of Terror these past few
years
I do think
that it can be mitigating
but I also feel that a lot of people
really leaned into their fear
a lot of people relished being fearful
and scared and helpless and hopeless
and
um I don't know I wouldn't want to be
the adjudicator of how much you did or
didn't and therefore how much uh
you know if you leaned into it if you
consciously allowed yourself to be more
scared more fearful
than you needed to be then I don't want
to mitigate then then you know you you
need to really own up
to all the stuff right more so
rather than if you actually were carried
away in a such that you absolutely could
not cause yourself to see reason because
you were so scared to overcome with fear
this is the sort of thing that obviously
you know court cases can hinge on with
regard to whether or not you had
the mental capacity to understand what
you were doing
I with those cases it's one of those
things I've always felt like I'm so glad
that I'm not in the business of
adjudicating these I just do not want to
be involved
um
I saw way too much
of
people
relishing Their Fear
um
I'm gonna go the other way and I'm going
to say
uh it's quite mitigating but only in one
circumstance which is that you own up to
the role that it played in unhooking
reason right and the point is look if
you don't own up to that yep if it's not
in your own analysis of how you screwed
this up then you're not safe because
that'll happen again yeah right but if
for example Sam oh yeah it was quite
clearly terrified of covid
and you know there was plenty of reason
to be frightened of it I I think it's
much more destructive than the case
fatality rate suggests but terrified is
not a reasonable it is not a position
conducive to reason as the as the
question suggests and so if Sam were to
say look
my fear got the better of me and it
caused me to misunderstand where I was
and who was speaking rationally then the
answer is well now we know something
which is that a you know that your fear
will do this and that means if it
happens again we can say hey Sam is it
happening again is this is your fear
driving yeah um yeah and so anyway I
would say it is very mitigating but only
if you push it to Consciousness and are
capable of recognizing what role it
played other than that the point is okay
that's a defect in your cognition and we
need to be concerned about what role it
plays in everything well I think that's
a better answer overall than the one I
gave
but I also mine is a narrower a narrower
response by a lot
um but I also do feel that it's relevant
I don't know how to um
how to make it manifest though like like
I said I don't know how to
operationalize the degree to which you
know you or you chose to be fearful
um maybe your answer
eliminates the need to but I'm not
compelled that it does well you know I
guess I I was steering clear of your
assertion that people were
inviting fear which strikes me as
totally plausible right people go to
horror films because there's some part
of them that Delights in fear and yeah
and I think
fortunately I think this is this is one
of these personality traits or
proclivities that is going to be
and I'm gonna use the word gendered here
because this is a place where we should
be able to talk about about sex
differences in Behavior which is
gendered
um average sex differences that um women
are more likely to be willing to be in
fear
um I think
uh and I think that some women will be
more likely to be totally unwilling like
no way no how not going to go there that
thing is dangerous
um but some I would think that being
willing to be in a fear would go hand in
hand with sort of wanting the you know
Prince Charming to ride over the horizon
wanting someone to come save you and so
they like the looking for authorities oh
isn't fauci so dreamy isn't this that
you know like looking for the person
who's going to come and rescue you from
your own fear and and hopelessness and
helplessness is extraordinarily
dangerous and I think is a big part of
what we were seeing through a lot of the
middle of the pandemic yeah I think so
too it's interesting you have exactly
the inverse uh
understanding of that pattern the narrow
part I would say men have an incentive
to get women into positions that trigger
Their Fear like going to a scary movie
right or uh but but we had a population
who was who would become fearful so you
know to the degree that fauci may you
know who who were the men here right
right so they were there were too many
there were too many and you know the
fact that a lot of the people who were
perpetrating the most damage we're women
you know the public figures like uh like
wolinsky like saki or pronounced that
you know Biden's
first or
press secretary
um but you know they were they were
encouraging the fear but it would have
worked differently right like they were
TR they were triggering the fear I think
mostly in women by being like you know
if you know if you care about your
children you will be just as scared and
do just as stupid of things as I'm doing
sort of thing right
um
whereas
yes I think in a in a
the word is abused but in a in a toxic
proto-relationship between a man and a
woman a man May exactly want to to make
a woman more fearful so that she feels
like she has to cling to him right in
order to be safe right right and I I do
think that there's a kind of a crossover
here that you're pointing to where
something figured out that it could
frighten people and I don't think we
know enough about maybe somebody does
but I don't know enough about what
people and it probably is very different
by by sex
what people tend to do when frightened
in other words the mass formation thing
people driven together in Terror yeah
right they may find each other they may
trust people that they would never trust
or even like under other circumstances
right because the point is it is you
know the huddled group in the cave with
the scary thing outside that you know
becomes the the mode of survival I felt
like circling the wagons to people I
think and you know for a while it was
those of us who were unvaccinated who
were the marauding hordes you know
putting them all at risk yep and you
know how was that made to be the
narrative
uh it wouldn't have worked if they
hadn't felt the need to circle the
wagons in the first place yep yep no
that's that's quite right it was like
you know the dimensionless Pod that was
immune from the virus fearful of those
who refused to do their part and had
become zombies right right yeah that was
the narrative and
um oddly didn't turn out to be that way
no it was the dimensionless Pod zombies
that we have to worry about yeah plot
twist
um
okay next question
although actually I feel like there is
one that was relevant to what you're
just talking about let me see if I can
quickly find it maybe not
um
this is a little bit this is not exactly
what I was thinking but friends and
family Etc labeled me as problematic
uh and worse when I objected after
getting pericarditis who was putting
whom at risk
so it's wow
yeah I have to say when I when I went to
the uh the conference in in Britain um
like May of this year yeah my
central theme and
the message that I believe needed to get
out was you can tell what this Beast is
by its gaslighting of the injured yeah
right if you think the injured are rare
then you ought to be very surprised that
it's treating these people as if they're
making it up right and then
um that the fact that it will Gaslight
the very people who in some cases signed
up for trials that weren't safe were
then injured and are now being treated
as pariahs that thing tells you you're
dealing with an immoral monster that
will do anything yeah it does
it does and this actually this is a
little bit related to
um the other day I saw a very long queue
of people it took me a moment to realize
they were lining up for vaccination
mostly older folk but a good minority of
younger people too
well I turn out to be overly pessimistic
that I saw this as a contemporary
version of Camp prisoners queuing for a
promised warm shower
question mark
from Matt in the UK
yeah I you know I don't I don't know
what to think
it seems to me you know if you think
back to the model that we were talking
about during the the podcast
um
it seems to me that the evidence that
should tell you that whatever mechanism
you were using to establish for yourself
what was true
an Ever larger fraction of people should
have run across some evidence that what
they were doing wasn't working yeah
right
a person that they know who's been
injured for example and that means that
the people who are still adhereing to
that narrative
very in deep whatever mechanism they're
using to fend off information is
industrial strength and you know that's
that's what I would think if I saw a
line of people still uh eager for this
in spite of the fact that
um you know the likelihood that it's
doing you more harm than good is quite
clear
does free will have to be a binary
one at degrees of freedom
it's not quite the right phrasing but
are we simply an object moving through
time and space along a predetermined
path or have we evolved a mental toolkit
which allows for some degree of
deviation from that path
perhaps a toolkit which can be upgraded
and improved allowing for greater
degrees of freedom as our truth-seeking
methodologies are refined yeah this is
exactly what I argued to Sam when I
talked to him about the switch was here
on Dark Horse like one of the very first
dark
it wasn't one of the very first it was
it was in the first 10 for sure was it
oh yeah okay well I've misremembered
where it was in any case
um my argument to Sam was look there is
some truth to the idea that we have far
less Free Will than we think and the
problem is at the place where we decide
that number might be zero it can't be
zero Sam you yourself are living proof
it's not zero and in fact much of what
you do is you try to liberate yourself
through contemplation and you know the
point is yes you have a little no it's
not as extensive as you think but you
want to live a life that means something
taking the little bit of free will you
have and using it to enlarge the amount
of free will that you actually have
realized Free Will is the game but you
know and I think this is where we hang
up is that people who hear you defend
free will think that you're saying oh
I'm totally free
right and here says no no it's very
small right we are mostly a set of
circuits and constraint constraint is
real and across you know all the domains
some of which some of which presumably
we have not yet defined in a way that is
the most useful to understand how it is
constraining us
um and
the the point it did not land for some
reason but the point I tried to use to
make this uh case to Sam was if we were
going to be truly unfree
one thing we can say is that selection
would arrange for anybody who had the
chance to produce lots of offspring
to do it and that Sam himself by
limiting himself to one family
is demonstrating that he is exercising
Free Will over the program
to which he would be helpless if
uh if Free Will was really a zero
I'm not sure I I feel like there there's
a better example I don't know what it is
but the reason that one doesn't work for
me so well is because
you know over an evolution space
obviously there are real considerations
about you know how far along sort of K
to are selected you're going to be and
how you know how much you're actually
going to leave an impacted genetic and
otherwise impact in the future depending
on how much you invest in a few I don't
remember where I put which but look how
much you invest in a few versus sort of
explosive breeding assemblages just you
know fertilize or produce as many eggs
as you can and then be gone and never
meet the kids so you know both both of
those are fit in the environments and
for the organisms which they have and so
saying you know it isn't a different
program that is also under some
circumstances uh fit and might be more
fit if you were employing it the thing
that you would be doing but for free
will strikes me as a little
yeah disappearing the analysis of mating
systems theory no because the fact is a
guy like Sam with resources attractive
guy well well-spoken
could fully Avail himself of the
opportunity that he's already invested
in and add to it opportunities that he's
not availing himself of
um
without compromising you know his uh his
case elected side
so
even if we take Sam out of the equation
which we probably should if the point is
if we were going to be unfree somewhere
it would be with respect to deploying
selections program for increasing
Fitness we would be we would have the
toughest time unhooking that one and
it's not the case right the fact is we
have a relatively easy job so you're not
you're not
arguing for a
a sort of a move into obvious polygyny
territory but rather a sort of you know
what Rich dudes who don't have the moral
sense that apparently
Sam does yep um right we'll often Avail
themselves up yeah but at the very least
we can just say generally we would
expect people deciding to do something
other than increase their Fitness that
would be very very I mean like take take
the following counter example okay
imagine that you wanted to take your
hand and put it into a pot of boiling
water
you would not have the free will to do
it you could not make yourself do it
right
so the point is you're very unfree there
you're more free to engage in Family
Planning prioritizing uh works of art
that you might want to create so the
question is why are you so free where
you would expect yourself to be
maximally constrained if Free Will is
zero yeah okay
okay
um I have to tell you that when you
put that image in my head of plunging
your own hand into the pot of boiling
water what occurred to me was now that
you have increased my own uncertainty in
whether or not my own knees are real I
think that I would be more willing to
plunge one of my knees into a vat of
boiling water not yet having had the
existence of my head called into
question because not the same like
different simulation I'm thinking right
oh absolutely your knees your knees are
there's some chance that the cost you
will pay before boiling away your knees
is zero
no one wants to incur the social penalty
of being branded a sexist racist or
transphobe what are the epithets for
indicting those who discriminate against
the unjabbed
I thought I'd I'd love to crowdsource
that I don't have anything offhand I
mean
okay I don't have the term yeah but
the idea is
there were all kinds of people
dragged into great Horrors
involved in the Holocaust involved in
gulags people have been dragged into
participating in in Horrors
that their conscious self would have
said violated their values and yet they
find themselves involved in it
and so the point is useful idiot doesn't
quite get you there but the idea that
you are somebody who could be drafted
into something that you would find vile
if we described it to you is the
indictment right that your thinking
capacity is feeble enough that you could
be one of them right yeah but I mean
that yes but too abstract like doesn't
make for an epithet right like I I
absolutely agree with you
but it's it's not pithy enough right
yeah we need we're at the boast I would
say like three words something right and
like you know sucker you know gullible
you know these things that's not it it's
it's it's too generic well it's
something like brown shirt all right
that's the
that's the category of person that one
would want to evoke now I'm not yeah but
again it's again it's an abstraction
about so
and that's not an epithet it's actually
a description of a of a population right
um
there's like a do you are you the type
of person who demonstrably follows
instructions even when it's bad for
everyone
uh and there's the you know are you a
demographic bigot
you know do you
um do you have
ludicrous senses of one or the other sex
some racists some races
um
trans people transphob is a different
category
um but you know
the unvaccinated like is there one for
what you got it right I kind of do have
it it's not gonna work
but I think it's awesome
Mobius brain
I get I mean that's funny I like it but
again it's I mean it's more like brown
shirts it's descriptive up to like how
did you end up here as opposed to this
is your conclusion right like racist
says like I don't know which race you're
like you've got some feelings against
but I know I know what that means
whereas
uh
I think you're throwing out Moby's brain
too quickly well but but you see the
different kind of categories I'm talking
about there's two different categories
one of them is this describes the
demographic thing that you have a bias
against
and one is you have a personality trait
or a mental defect or something that
allows you to end up becoming a brown
shirt and it's called Mobius brain right
like there's that thing and then there's
like what is the demographic group that
you are bigoted against
is it a racial group is it a is it a sex
is it uh people in support of medical
Freedom right
yeah yeah I see it I see the problem
I don't have anything it's not like
um it's not like I'm saying no I like
mine better I don't have one but I but I
would like
um you know maybe
I would I would actually be interested
in crowdsourcing and answer to that so
um you know a tweet that uh
that tagged
one or both of us that uh
might be useful yep
can we please stop using the term
democracy like it's a good thing when
what we want is a republic
the difference being you can't vote
certain things away in the latter
two wolves and a sheep as the saying
goes
I don't know what the two Wolves and the
sheep saying refers to and I admit that
I'm not
educated enough I wouldn't have been
able to come up with the difference
between the two
being that you can't vote certain away
certain things away in a republic but
you can't a democracy nor can I fact
check that claim although this is
someone who writes in a lot and I trust
them in general the problem is I'm not
sure that I'm not sure you want to get
rid of it because you want to get rid of
the term democracy the use as if it is a
positive trade okay because I mean
really the the right trait the one that
precisely describes the thing that is of
value is consent of the governed
consent of the governed is the sole
source of legitimacy of governance right
the consent of the government
and so we don't have a democracy in the
sense that we don't vote on everything
and we don't have a representative
democracy because we do have
constitutional principles that are not
up for debate
although they are up for Amendment so in
some sense They Are Up For Debate
it's not a good thing but it's an
indirect representative democracy
um
it is an indirect representative
Democratic Republic
the core thing that must be defended
against all
antagonistic principles is the consent
of the governed it is imperfect but the
point is it is vital and if you
eliminate that you could have one
generation of benevolent dictator but
that's it we don't have a mechanism for
picking benevolent dictators so the
point is you'd have to get lucky and get
one and you wouldn't get two and so
disaster so the point is we are left
with consent of the governed as the
thing that must be that's the hill to
die on and
um
the problem is that you know do you want
to go through the process of educating
the public that it's speaking
too imprecisely when it says democracy
and that it really needs to think about
the consent of the governed being the
sole source of legitimacy of governance
I think that's that's a mouthful so
yeah but I mean maybe maybe uh marushia
here is uh arguing for Precision in our
speech
well I mean you know I do try to speak
of uh of the consent of the governed
it's a very you know it's uh
protection under these are there certain
phrases that really do function as the
the underlying operating system and I do
try to you know it's not that I never
say democracy
um but I do try to to use those phrases
to keep them
um
uh
alive and in in conscious thought
I mean you know and I try to
prune the bad ones right Law and Order
that's not uh that's not good
the one we should use is rule of law
right you want the rule of law law and
order is kind of a reactionary uh desire
to police things rather than an
agreement that what we need are explicit
uh rules that we know about can
understand and can that a reasonable
person can follow and not worry about
the police if they do right
so anyway yes it's a good instinct to do
this precisely but you can't always yep
okay
um I know we've been at it for a while
but we've barely touched barely
scratched yeah we're gonna do several
more and then um
boy I just don't know if we're gonna
have a q a for a couple weeks after this
so I don't just do as many as we can
here
um have you seen the mysterious beasts
of spiden Island yet
you can sometimes spot them on the shore
if you sail by in a quiet Sloop
speaking of which I highly recommend
getting a small day sailor around 15 to
25 feet long best way to explore the San
Juans anyway bring your cameras on this
adventure love you guys
um we are definitely not going to do the
spider Island thing until uh the sun
until we are on the other side of the
sun and the days are getting longer and
warmer but it is definitely on the list
did you have an idea what he's talking
about all right 100 mysterious beasts oh
yeah really yeah it was a hunting it was
a hunting lodge and it has all of these
I think all African exotic species on
it's long since oh I guess I didn't know
know this yeah so it's not it's so the
San Juans where we now live is this the
southern part of an archipelago that
includes the gulf Islands which are
Canadian uh and on the American part
there are four islands that are fairly
served and we live on one of them and
then there are a whole lot of other I
don't know if it's more than 100
probably must be many yeah yeah so not
100 probably but but more than a hundred
total but of the other inhabited Islands
there are dozens yeah
um so obviously you need your own boat
if you if you live on one of those and
spyden is one of them but despite and
not have people spyden is a private
island so one one family or something
family owns it yeah it has these weird
fauna left on it I think you remember
this now from years ago yeah not allowed
to land on it but you can go by
and the creatures are I've looked at for
them on satellite I mean I don't see
them but um
that's cool yeah but anyway yeah for
sure that's awesome I feel like at one
point I mean we've been we've been
trying to move up here for ages back
before we could ever actually really
consider it and um did manage to look at
various islands that we you know were
even farther out of side of our reach
because they would have required a boat
which we have never had
um but I remember hearing this story yes
yeah yes at this point but have not have
not been there I know we don't have a
quiet Sloop
nope this Loop is loud as hell
what are you talking about do we have a
boat I don't know about no no please
tell me we don't
not that I not that there's not some
interest in that but if I don't know
about it there might be a problem right
okay
um
it seems rhetorical and also like an
answer is necessary when I'm listening
to almost all of accepted media I'm told
something different especially about
vaccination and all things coven how do
I know what to believe anymore
it actually says vacation not
vaccination but I'm assuming in context
what was it was vaccinations yeah
you can combine them now
um yeah I'm told something different
about vacation I'd love to hear the
media just take on vacation in wildly
disparate ways that could be fun that
could be an amusing Endeavor but um
I mean this just it's this hopeless
truth of modernity that many people are
awake to and the fact that so many
people aren't awake to it is
the thing that can render you even more
hopeless right I think
the sad fact is
you should stop listening to things that
chronically lie to you
that many things that didn't always
chronically lie to you now do
so at the point that you know you detect
that the New York Times May
spout pure propaganda
uh on certain topics
you shouldn't take it very seriously
when it uh tries to present a nuanced
case around uh Sam bankman freed right
yeah
um so the point is okay I'm not
listening to that outlet because that
outlet has proved that it isn't a
newspaper okay
and then if you know once you start
looking for things that a don't do that
they don't lie and then B
within the category of things that don't
lie you look for things that have a
predictive track record and you know
nothing's gonna have a perfect record
but things that have a predictive track
record and things that correct their own
errors
uh are things you can listen to do you
trust them completely no but you can
eliminate the possibility
or almost eliminate the possibility that
they're ill-intentioned yeah right but
yeah don't don't give your
intellectual proxy that's not quite the
right framing but like don't give your
intellectual proxy entirely over to
anyone but and you know we've we've said
this before and I think we actually say
this in our book as well uh we both used
to begin our
programs when we were teaching at
Evergreen uh very first day by saying
don't don't trust me
you know I'm I'm the person that the
school hired and you you're here and I'm
not your employee like you don't work I
don't work for you we would say to the
students but also just because I'm here
with some terminal degree in a in a
field that is related to something you
think you want to learn about doesn't
mean that I'm trustworthy or honest or
have anything uh useful to tell you
because many faculty don't
um so you know we we had to earn
students trust and we told them that
you know that you know if if five weeks
in
they were still questioning every single
utterance out of our mouth that's that's
exhausting and and pointless
right
um but you know as as any source
reliably proves that it is it knows what
it's doing and makes predictions that
are borne out then you put more and more
of your
faith for lack of a better term here in
that Source but that faith is based that
trust that trust is based on what you
know what came what already came which
doesn't immunize you from a long con of
course not but
um one thing I want to it's not really a
correction but when you describe what we
said to students don't trust me isn't
really the meaning right and you got
there in the end but the point is don't
trust me because I've been put in front
of you true right yes I want you to
trust me yeah but I want you to arrive
at that trust I don't want you to start
out with the fact that I walked into the
room with a degree and a sheet of all of
your names right is not reason to trust
me right right many people who will do
that are not worthy of your trust right
um
so anyway yeah it is it is a good
principle and you know I would also say
dividing trust into two things
uh is essential
you can trust somebody completely with
respect to character it might be wrong
but it is not illogical to trust
somebody's character right their values
what they say that they are what they
say they are
it is a mistake to trust anybody
completely at the level of judgment even
yourself right the point is judgment is
a flawed process and if you just say
well I really trust that person and you
don't distinguish between their values
and their judgment you will get into
trouble because they will make an error
and so they were trying to make the
error but you've got to be aware that
your your trust should be a lot harder
to earn at the point of view from the
perspective of
um judgment than uh decency yeah
my doctor's one by one chased me away
because of my choice to not get the Jab
do you have a plan in place for medical
attention
um
you know I had I and we had found a
number of people in Portland uh who were
not allopathic doctors
who did excellent work and delivered
excellent medical treatment we did not
have a plan in place for an emergency
that would send a person to the
emergency room
still don't yep uh and you know by
moving I've moved away from the um the
small but excellent
set of Health practitioners whom we had
found uh in Portland
um
I think I've said this on air too but I
at one point maybe last winter we still
lived in Portland I fell
this piece of
pipe sticking up and I fell and I cut
myself on the pipe and I fell in
concrete it was icy and I was all alone
at the house I was really cold out it's
dark like every everything was bad about
it and uh I had I'm usually not a
fearful person
uh and and apropos our conversation from
earlier I I do take pride in that in not
succumbing to fear and and you know
giving my wits about me and such but I
realized as I was sort of landing and I
had this fear and the fear was not oh my
God what if I'm injured like I've been
really injured and I've gotten better
and I feel like I know that I can
recover from phys most physical injury
at this point my fear was
oh my God I'm injured such that I'm
going to need to go to the hospital all
right
and uh it's a it's a real problem now
and I don't I don't have a general
answer yeah we don't have a we don't
have a good answer we do have
um lots of people who care about us who
are doctors who have fought the same
fight and so from the point of view of
can we get eyes on a situation I think
we're in the best position of anybody
right we've got the best doctors and
we've been fighting shoulder to shoulder
with them that does not answer the
question of what you do if you're being
rushed to the emergency room right we
don't know and uh you know at the moment
we are crossing our fingers that this
doesn't happen but that's long-term we
can't live like this and how we rescue
the doctors who were dragged early into
assertions about Kobe that turned out
not to be true how we recover a
relationship with them so they can go
back to doctoring and never do that
again I don't know but it is kind of the
question because it was like they
sidelined an entire profession in one go
yeah and it's a profession we need
we need it
totally different topic here
um actually you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
come back to this one for sure but let's
just stick with something similar for a
little bit with the decreasing birth
rate and increasing death rate among the
vast will politicians be held to account
foreign
doubt it
yep
doubt it too
uh emergencies act inquiry is underway
Trudeau now looks more like a vacuous
tyrant
yep vacuous Tyrant a lot of fur was just
released yep um it's all over my pants
already wow
um
evacuous Tyrant yep a um
what kind of candle duplicitous
duplicitous Kendall why do I always
forget that it's so brilliant
duplicitous Ken doll yeah
yeah that's sort of just a comment
um
okay we'll go back to the one I was
going to uh which is rather different
topic any advice for those of us raising
young boys and how to deal with the porn
issue as they get older parentheses
sorry if this talk topic embarrasses you
Zach
um I would actually
um
I don't think I would I
it would be fascinating to have you and
your son your older son our producer
have a conversation in public about this
yep um because he has
um
I don't think he's what's that happy too
cool yeah not not embarrassed and feels
um
feels very strongly about it and sees
what he sees among his generation as
well so but so let's
table that for right now
um but I want to give I want to give a
short yeah uh answer to the question and
then we can return to it
the short answer of the question is it
couldn't really be more dangerous the
thing that is being sold especially to
young men is
um
something that it you know at best will
[ __ ] and tremendously alter their
sexual selves and so being clear with
your kid that it's not this isn't the
you know
stigma of pornography that existed when
we were kids right where the porn
Playboy under your mattress right
exactly this is about something this is
about your own well-being and I your
parent am speaking to you on behalf of
your future self you do not want to let
these people access your sexual mind
because it will distort your
relationship sex is a very important
tool in the relationship toolkit and if
you let these money obsessed people
alter your sexual self because it
enriches them you're affecting your
relationship with the people or the
person who will be the most important
person in your life
right so don't do it this is you talking
to you through me it's not me talking to
you it's not this isn't about me this is
about you
um
when a dog stand up yeah
um what's going on here come on up doggy
come on
all right you work on the questions I'm
working about
um
predictable
um
that was a great answer and I'm I
actually
yeah let us let us return to the
question of whether or not a
conversation I I think that between the
two of you could
should should happen publicly I think
that would be incredibly powerful and
eye-opening
Madison
you have never not been allowed on this
couch
ER knows that gets her up there well
like don't just tap it
I meant like
come here come on sweetie
foreign
apparently neither of us have the magic
Zach
okay
what is hyper okay
did it
what is hyperactivity is it mostly
learned is it linked to Consciousness or
no is it linked to conscientiousness
that's what it says I don't know
I don't know which of those two words
she means this is Echo love to you too
what is hyperactivity is it mostly
learned is it linked to
conscientiousness is what she's
I would guess that this is a mixture of
several different phenomena one is hyper
novelty that we live in circumstances
that are you know the child is not
supposed to be
sitting
nicely facing forward mining his matters
the child is supposed to be out in the
bush you're supposed to be sort of aware
where the child is but the child is
supposed to be learning the lessons of
life from the world yes and so our novel
world has put children in a situation
where they may be fidgety antsy whatever
and uh it's not an indicator of any it's
a mismatch between the child and the
environment not a defect yeah well it's
a it's a defect but not in the child in
the environment right it's a defect in
the environment is there a pathology in
which that defect is
the result is exacerbated by something
in the child that's off undoubtedly sure
is it further exacerbated by a
pharmaceutical industry that wants to
sell you some pill to deal with it so
have they increased the definition of
they broadened it so they can diagnose
more people and Drug them with something
that ostensibly has some useful effect
and so those three combine those three
things and you will get an answer in
which it's partially a PR campaign by PR
partially a mismatch between child and
environment and partially something that
may be pathological as a result of
Developmental disturbance or whatever
which itself is brought on
um not just by the school environment
but the food environment and the family
environment the media environment to let
in the water environment that you know
like you know hyper novelty which is
where you started like all all of the
environments like is there a defect here
yeah there's a lot of defects here uh
has it been uh has it gone on for so
long that the child is now irrecoverably
uh defective
probably not you know especially a young
kid probably if you fix all the
environmental problems that are going on
um you you know for them usually you're
going to have a kid who's a decent
interesting kid but will that decent
interesting kid ever be able to sit
straight in rows and raise their hand
whenever they want to utter something or
go pee no and that doesn't say anything
about how awesome and decent that kid is
yep
to do
I don't know who this person is would
you consider a podcast with raheen Kasam
do you know the name nope
um I also don't know what this refers to
but I'll go for it
the origin story of the woman of
Willendorf seems off
does a time traveling Nicole Kidman have
no shot in the prehistoric dating Market
Canadian would be referred to
that I know who Nicole Kidman is
terrific yep we enter with the same
amount of insufficient knowledge on that
one sorry
um okay one more of these so I'm just
gonna go with you like hi is there any
chance to invite Dr Sabine Hassan as a
guest
she's doing great job regarding the
covet Ivermectin got in a microbiome
people need to hear more about her work
don't know that one either we do have
someone who's supposed to be going oh
actually not through the questions you
should have them go into the questions
too and picking up recommendations and
uh have someone going through comments
actually on YouTube so I actually you
know put those of you who asked
questions like this if you put them in a
comment on YouTube they should get
picked up and at some point we may see
them again it's not the promises here
but
um I don't Grouch your complaints with
elon's Mars mission we only have one
planet we could have two
why risk all eggs in one basket also why
not interview him like you did with
shellenberger
musk easier said than done on that one
yeah glad boy there's so many things I
would love to talk uh with him about if
he's interested uh definitely yeah
my problem is not that there's anything
wrong with the idea of going to Mars in
fact I think I've argued on Dark Horse
that it will be terrifically valuable to
go through the exercise of getting
people to Mars setting up a colony if we
can bringing people back alive all of
those things
are great goals even if there's nothing
on Mars for us even if terraforming Mars
and making it habitable is unlikely I
will also say that there's the
possibility that something like uh AGI
would allow us to terraform Mars in a
way that is unforeseeable from here but
not that many years in the future I
don't want to go is kind of my objection
it's not an interesting place it's not
going to be an interesting place even if
you terraformed it you're going to
terraform it with things that work it's
not going to be the beautiful
fascinating planet that I live on yeah
yeah and so anyway all I'm arguing is
two things one Mars sucks more than you
think
so much more so much more than you think
so much more um and two the idea that
our ability to inhabit it meaningfully
is close enough that it constitutes a
second basket for the eggs in the near
term is simply wrong yeah but am I for
us going absolutely hell yeah as long as
us doesn't necessarily include you or me
or it's not going to I can I can I can
uh disappoint them now and just say I
you can have my seat give it to someone
else give it to someone in a sec I think
you could have seven or eight hours of
interesting exploration there
come on back yeah on Mars yeah oh yeah I
think there's plenty oh yeah day trip
yeah
yeah day trip to Mars
yep yeah no and I guess I wonder
um because we've heard versions of this
question before like what the hell is
your problem isn't this isn't this
obviously the thing we want and
um and no I mean the person asking this
question is very respectful and all
um but I think
I think in part this reveals something
that's just a really fundamental
truth about you and me and our family
with and it's it's a large part of why
we became the kinds of biologists that
we did like you've got we go outside
and we see things we didn't expect even
if we go outside the same front door
we've been going out for you know months
or years or decades depending on where
we are at the moment and that's
magical and you can understand that
magic with science and with creativity
and with everything and an entirely
created landscape hello friend
um
just doesn't have the potential to have
that kind of surprise in it
this does though yes this little critter
that just came down my shoulder
um okay it is we've been going out for a
while we're gonna just do a couple more
here
um hello friend
I don't really understand this one I'm
gonna read it scam artists share lists
of the victims who they succeed in
fooling this is why I think we can't
ever trust those who fell for covet
again
foreign
get the connection between those two
parts
well I think I kind of do hey I'm not
sure how much truth there is in this it
seems to me
that people who fall for cons yes that
would be a valuable list for other
current artists to be able to access but
also if you're a con artist why would
you
yeah why would you burn such a valuable
asset yeah
um
I think the implication of the question
I'm not sure whether I buy it or not
is that if these people have signaled
that they are you know that upon
discovering a trojan horse that they
will open the gates of the city that
they are going to be utilized
against us again
[Music]
maybe they're going to be utilized
against us again
um
yeah okay well
yeah so maybe the first part doesn't
even
it's unnecessary here because we can all
see you know like
I mean and we have talked about like to
what degree was there
are there intentional in advance or used
once it was happening like oh now we
know now we know that this set of people
will fall into lockstep quickly and this
set of people requires a little bit more
coercion and this set of people requires
a couple of lines of evidence and you
know the set of people aren't swayed by
Hollywood but they are swayed by the
CDC in the who and what that there's
that there's information there for sure
but this is
I think I wish I had said this two hours
ago
this is part of why it is important that
we not
balkanize social media to the extent
that people who got this wrong now go to
their own sites where they get to
rationalize in isolation yeah they're
going to get it wrong and they're going
to remain dangerous to the extent that
we all come to some kind of natural
conclusion about what happened how many
people were fooled what sorts of things
fooled them and the point is we all get
safer because you know
the right thing is for us to immunize
ourselves from uh
great resetters who are unelected and
have decided to remake our world without
our consent right right how we make
ourselves immune from Pharma which has a
game in which it would like to medicate
us with things that always have
side effects and you know yep uh that
may not be effective how to immunize us
from
um
Public Health
megalomaniacs who would Institute a
campaign that might stick us permanently
with a virus that maybe could have been
eliminated right all of these things are
really important and if we break into
separate conversations then the point is
what do you think the chances are that
the people who got this wrong are going
to find their way to Clarity I'd say
that's real close to zero yeah
okay
two last quick questions and then we'll
stop all right
WC which I think here means World Cup
this is the World Cup and Qatar right
now I believe so okay World Cup and
Qatar how do I cope with the corruption
that is ruining the sport I love
I don't actually know what's happening
in soccer that is
described here as the corruption ruining
the sport that this person loves I don't
know either I do I did briefly take an
interest in the corruption surrounding
the Olympics which was jaw-dropping
because basically that there's a
cabal of
wealthy influential people who decide
for example where the games will be held
and because there's such a huge amount
of resource riding on where the games
are held this is a you know thoroughly
corrupt process I don't know I would
assume the same thing is in soccer at a
smaller scale what effect it has on
actual play I don't know yeah
um but anyway I'd be curious to know
what the corruption is doing yeah
okay I know I said uh just two more but
one one more in the style of suggestions
for possible
um
people interact with now that Sargon of
akkad is back on Twitter would love to
see you to do an interview either on
Dark Horse or loaded Cedars or both
yep I think it uh it would be cool
um
he has a real name I've forgotten it
Carl Benjamin Carl Benjamin that's right
yes
um finally love the armadillo painting
is it possible for me to acquire one
love you both it's Ashia mosaic
it's a it's a bunch of uh ceramic tiles
made by a ceramicist in Cuenca in
Ecuador famous surroundings famous
ceramicist in Cuenca we went to his
studio and gallery and bought this there
and bought some other Awesomeness from
him as well I have a soft spot for
Ceramics and when it combines biology
with Ceramics I mean what how can you
how could you go wrong and probably if
I'd seen this question earlier I would
have checked and I'm sure the artist's
name is on the back there but if
probably if you Google up ceramicist and
Cuenca c-u-e-n-c-a Ecuador you will find
uh this I believe I've been to the site
and I believe you could certainly get
something of the sort you might
uh you know he is famous enough that he
produces uh multiples of things yeah
it's one it's one of these people that
he you know he's doing production work
so you know this is this is actually
came out of his Gallery but it was
probably you know he designed the
original but it was probably actually
made by
um an underlying outside sunderling
Potters yep yeah yeah you can actually
at um goink is a cool Town yeah it is uh
if you ever get the chance to go to
Cuenca you can go on a tour of his uh
Studio yeah and you can actually there's
big glass windows you can look down on
how these things are made anyway yeah
it's a it's a cool thing yeah it's very
cool and I'm not you know so I think I
think we all went some of our students
went as well but um I knew I was going
to be excited by it because I've been a
ceramicist
um but everyone who I think went whether
or not they had any past experience with
clay and glaze and such or not uh was
intrigued yep oh he's stuck
um
all right
I think that's it that's it I think
that's it you've arrived we've arrived
uh we will be
sex making faces he's doing face bomb
over there
um
we will be back here
at 9 45 Pacific time tomorrow we're
actually going to start we're gonna do a
full hour but only an hour we're gonna
stop on the hour uh what we're calling
just a holiday gift episode of Dark
Horse and then after that and that's
going to be available publicly and then
after that we're gonna do our private q
a on patreon with a bunch of questions
that have already been asked but uh it's
a lot of fun and we get to interact with
the audience on those so that's at 11AM
tomorrow Pacific you can access the link
for that um shortly at my patreon and
regardless if you're on my patreon or
not you can join us both at the live
stream tomorrow at 9 45. anything else
to say before we sign off I think we've
done it I think we've done it well until
next time be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]